in this video we're going to talk about
analog versus digital something that's
analog can be any value within a given
range while something digital is
represented by a number of discrete or
separate levels
to distinguish these two ideas i like to
think about clocks an analog clock has
the numbers in the hands and it's analog
because the motion of those hands is
continuous they can sweep across the
circle representing any of infinite
times on that clock for example between
306 and 307 the minute hand is actually
going to be at some point between those
marks on the clock
showing one of the infinitely possible
times that the clock can represent
compare that to a digital clock a
digital clock is only going to show you
306 or 307
it will never display any of the many
fractional seconds between those two
times
digital only takes on certain discrete
values and it has a finite number of
those values
so an analog waiver signal will smoothly
sweep across the infinitely many
possible values it has
while a digital waiver signal will only
be at one of a number of discrete values
so the shape of the wave will be more
square or step like
let's check out an example so this makes
a little more sense i like music so
we're going to talk about sound
sound is an analog signal or wave so if
we look at a graph of sound volume over
time it's going to have a smooth
continuous analog waveform both the
amplitude or the volume and the
frequency what we hear as pitch
are changing continuously between
infinite possible values all right and
that's because sound waves the vibration
of particles propagating through the air
actually changes continuously the very
first sound recording and reproduction
technology imprinted that analog wave
directly onto a material for example
records imprint that sound wave into
vinyl and cassettes and print the sound
wave onto tape
a major drawback of this technology is
that for the sound to play back exactly
as it was recorded that waveform needs
to stay untouched right so think about
scratching vinyl or stretching or
smudging a cassette tape that's directly
deforming the wave so you'll never be
able to reproduce the sound exactly as
it was recorded
so technology advanced and sound waves
became digitized here's how
alright so recall our analog sound wave
we have a smooth analog wave that's
taking on any number of infinitely
possible values within this range
in order to digitize this wave we're
going to describe numbers to the
amplitude at different points all right
watch as magic
so we go over here and make a scale so
we're breaking up the amplitudes into
discrete possibilities
then we can go through the wave and at
specific points of the wave measure what
is the amplitude based on that scale
so over here we're at the first point of
the scale
at this peak we're at the second point
of our scale then the first the third
the second the fourth
back down to the first
now that we have this wave broken up
into discrete levels right we can
ascribe the numbers and we effectively
turn this analog wave into a set of
numbers
one two one three two four one
our wave has been digitized
now that digitized wave can be played
back through a speaker to recreate the
analog wave as long as a sampling
happens at a quick enough rate humans
can't tell the difference
alright so the digitization of waves is
all about ascribing specific numbers to
some of those mechanical properties of
the wave
the important thing here is that now
that the wave has been digitized
the digitized sound wave can be reliably
stored processed and communicated with
computers
so some information is lost in
translation but once the wave is
digitized its quality will never degrade
okay and that allows for a lot more
reliable technology because the wave is
represented with numbers instead of it
being physically imprinted on some
material
so humans prefer to store information
like sound digitally and there are ways
to turn analog signals which can
represent any of infinite possible
values into digital information which is
useful because information is stored
only at a number of discrete or separate
levels